after yesterday's show we got a chance
to talk to Mike Tyson he was in Los
Angeles and you'll notice or you'll be
able to hear
Mike's eating cereal at the time it was
an interesting interview and I started
by asking Mike Tyson if he watched the
34:30
on Buster Douglas the 42 to 1 no no
interest no I was going through the
television around two o'clock in the
morning last night I was watching myself
getting punched around so ok when you're
watching yourself getting punched what
are you thinking about that does it take
you back to that that moment there with
Buster Douglas why not
doesn't do you did you choose not to
just think about it anymore and like
those fights are such a distant memory I
don't think about any of my fight
really it seems so old it's so
antiquated but we're so fascinated with
it but you have no N no curiosity no
interest at all I guess because you did
it right
it's like a blur like it never happened
okay but can you indulge me with just
what do you remember about when you were
in Japan like the fact that they had to
have it in Japan because I don't think
anybody was gonna take the fight here
they didn't know if anybody would show
up in the United States to see it and
that's because a buster not you but what
do you remember about being I'll get my
ask when did you know you were in
trouble with Buster
I don't know then totally happen until
they stopped it ain't no and it's never
over till it's over
when you walked into the ring you didn't
seem like your normal presence when you
walked into the ring you guys kind of
beat me on that quick count though that
was a fast count when you went down yeah
I said that long account that he had
yeah the time I rip you off when that
though so you think that it was
definitely long they they thought it
maybe it was 12 or 13 seconds well you
know it was just in this kind of depend
on me to film one and count it yeah did
you think you got and plus he was Saved
by the Bell - mm-hmm
because I get the feeling that you would
have moved in for the kill
sensing that you know you just knocked
him down you didn't get that chance and
they never fought me again either those
bums but why didn't you guys have a
rematch in in this day and age where you
make somebody have one - he didn't want
to fight no more why I don't know they
didn't want to fight no more you want to
fight somebody out to get less money how
about we set it up now you again can you
take Buster now that would be funny
though
that'd be a funny funny or Die where we
get both you guys in there for the
rematch and you guys just lean on each
other
no no punches are thrown there do you
miss throwing a punch
no I over there can you learn how to
take a punch I know man I just think I'm
just gotta grow up around this to be in
the gym I've been in the gym so I was 12
years old
I'm just moving and ducking punches for
a long time so it became just became
part of my life but I'm wondering if
you're teaching somebody who just
learned how to box like you have to take
a punch to learn to be able to take a
punch but it's just natural that you
either got you know a glass
Dutch in or you got the toughness to be
able to stand in there anything you have
to have the discipline you have the
discipline to be able to want to do this
the determination and the will to win to
do this stuff it's really a complex for
it could you teach somebody your style
of boxing I don't think I could but if I
got a 12 year old 13 year old wanted to
learn so you couldn't say this is how I
did it because I don't know if anybody's
like you did I don't know if I could
[Music]
where do you think the sport of boxing
is headed hey the last heavyweight fray
was a good fight so I don't know it
could be could have some room and Tyson
Fury and I say why are those exciting
fight those kinds yeah and then there's
gonna be a rematch there because of the
controversy hey what did you think of
that judging I didn't see the whole
Friday sort of knockdown yeah seemed a
little shaky there that you know it's
almost like you know you got three
different people watching a fight and
then you got somebody who watches it
completely different did you ever feel
like you got screwed with a judge no no
you never had any controversies like
that no what's the what's the thing
you're doing now yeah I'm opening up my
weed empire your weed empire explain we
have a marijuana Empire the cannabis
Empire that we started two years ago and
where's it gonna be and how are you how
are you distributing it like the Palm
Springs datastream they're here I know
are you are you going to be working on
the ranch well I'm not gonna be working
on their ranch
no okay the universities go to be on the
property yeah and then he's Theater for
concerts so you wait you're gonna have a
university yes educate the people on
cannabis
what's the name of the university going
to be well forget that it could be
cannabis university or university
whatever we can be university
do you use weed do you smoke or have
edibles yeah I do
how long have you smoked or eat well my
wife basically oh really yeah was it
okay I think I'd never doubt he did it
one time when I was fighting when it was
uh when I fought gerado
the only time I smoked leaning for it
and how it affect you it didn't affect
me it affects the gladder wait you're
getting high in the locker room and then
you go out and take it out on galata so
okay and that's the only time you ever
got high before you fought yeah they
fined me like a plan with also when you
took your your blood test or your urine
test and yeah did you smoke after most
of your fights no no just that one time
it felt like you know after so then
after the Selden fight I smoked you know
you do Bruce Seldon doesn't it yeah but
it felt like you were were you medicated
at all before you fought Buster like you
seemed very quiet when you got like here
there was something I don't remember
none of that stuff back then man really
yeah yeah I could train better
it wasn't in great shape I have a train
better he has fought a good night and
had a great night that night yeah I had
a lot of great nights oh you had well
what's the best night you ever had I
don't know
I was there for the Frazier fight and I
I think I sat down and then it was over
I had a full beer I was really young
back then oh my god yeah I think the
first time I met you was 1986 at Gus's
house and cus was no longer alive and
then his wife was there but I remember
going there and and then I got to see
that fight I saw the Spinks fight to
ringside that didn't last long either
Mike I want my money back I didn't get
my money's worth when I watched you
fight Mike Mike I saw fear in that that
poor little guy's eyes when I'd solve
for a I saw fear in his eyes you saw it
too isn't it crazy like it was a year
comes every year that goes by but I was
actually about the fight of the year
they put they have a special about the
fight why are we found so fascinated by
it I don't know well you just I mean
you're you're the baddest man on the
planet you get in the ring you got no
robe you got I mean all you want to do
is just like it was like you were saying
I got five minutes and I got to knock
this guy out and I got to be someplace
and you just charged out and then you
could just see him saying just make it
make it and quick is what I thought
Frazier was saying and so did spin
Spinks was a great fighter he just never
should have been in there with you right
I mean that's why we were fascinated you
you went in there and it looked like you
were going to explode yeah I really
about my marijuana company this is
really good you hate talking about your
career doing
Oh No my career was closed I'm into
doesn't stuff now really you're
fascinating about my company and what
I'm doing now how do you find out more
about your company
it's our website we get to go on website
I see ranch just Tyson ranch calm yeah
they give you a location you need but if
I hang it the at the University if I go
to the ranch when you go to the ranch
you might become a member of the
University is there a graduate school
there can I get a law degree there at at
Tyson University well good luck with
this good luck with nice
Tyson ranch and and this is a message to
everybody else in the media
don't ask Mike about his boxing career
he doesn't want to talk about it anymore
there there's a public what if I send if
I send Buster Douglas - Tyson ranch that
would be pretty often his life yeah
and he looks at if he has a little bit
of marijuana he's gonna need to eat a
whole lot when he gets there - look he
needs he's gonna get come he's gonna get
some munchies hey good luck with it Mike
always great to talk to you thanks for
joining us Thank You Ben for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show ass
[Music]